I know watch spin to the Oval Office
unlike most people many times but this
is a very special time for you this is a
tremendous award you have the
Congressional Medal of Honor and the
military's which of course is something
incredibly special and the Presidential
Medal is I just want to congratulate you
there's nothing like it thank you very
much
joining us for this momentous ceremony
are art six children thank you very much
congratulations and we're also grateful
to be joined by Vice President Mike
Pence we just got back from Florida on a
big night that was a big night in
Orlando Mike Wright secretary Steve
minuchin Alex Acosta Elaine Chao and Ben
Carson thank you very much for being
here
and our top economic adviser and a great
friend of all of us actually I hear that
voice and I just say money money money
Larry Kudlow right few people in history
have revolutionized economic thought and
policy like dr. art Laffer he developed
a brilliant theory shaped unprecedented
economic reforms and helped turn a
severe recession into a remarkable boom
he proved that the most powerful way to
grow the economy and raise government
revenue was not to increase tax rates
but to adopt strong incentives that
Unleashed the power of human freedom and
innovate create jobs and deliver greater
opportunity to all Americans and he's
proved it over and over again a Yale
graduate art went on to earn his PhD in
economics from Stanford University he
became the youngest ever tenured
professor at the University of Chicago
that's good that wasn't too long ago was
he's very deceiving he's a little older
than he looks he looks like he's in his
40s he's a little older than that just a
little bit don't talk about it in 1970
art served as the very first chief
economist at the Office of Management
and Budget where he designed an economic
model that is still used today to
forecast tax revenue and accurately
predict economic growth art then
returned to the University of Chicago at
the start of the Ford administration our
nation's economic situation was becoming
dire indeed we remember in 1974 alone
two million Americans joined the
unemployment lines and inflation hit 11%
right now we have inflation at almost
nothing I like that better than it's
good to read this because we read this
that we realize how well we're doing
right now the consensus in Washington on
both sides of the aisle was that the
government could tax inflate and
regulate its way to prosperity but art
had a different idea right you did have
a different idea I'd have you tell it
would be much more interesting that in
1974 art came to dinner with the White
House chief staff chief of staff Don
Rumsfeld deputy chief of staff
Dick Cheney who's been by the way a
tremendous supporter and we appreciate
dick very much and Wall Street Journal
reporter Jude one iski the dinner has
since become very very legendary in many
minds art drew on his napkin a series of
lines and a curve that changed history
with the now famous Laffer curve still a
very very highly respected economic
curve art showed that if tax rates are
too high people stop spending and they
stop investing the result is less growth
at lower tax revenues on the other hand
at the certain point on the curve lower
tax rates spur investment economic
growth
and raise government revenue I think
Steve Forbes agrees with that we're
Steve right I've heard you for a long
time talking about that very much agree
prominent academics call this theory
insanity totally wacky and completely
off the wall with optimism confidence
and exceptional intellect art would go
on to prove them all wrong he proved
them wrong on a number of occasions in
1978 California Governor Jerry Brown
asked art to help him implement
proposition 13 which the people had
overwhelmingly enacted to dramatically
reduce the state property tax I think
they could use it again out there by the
way they should do that immediately the
results were so successful that job
creation soon grew at twice the
nationwide rate within two years 43
states adopted similar reforms during
that same period art also advised Ronald
Reagan and helped shaped his low tax
pro-growth agenda after President
Reagan's election art served on the
president's economic policy advisory
board he played a vital role in both the
1981 and 1986 tax rate cuts which
ultimately lowered the top marginal tax
rate from 70% to 28% that's not bad
that's a pretty big reduction I would
say the Reagan economy soared creating
sustained economic growth shrinking
poverty expanding incomes and
dramatically increasing federal revenue
sounds very familiar sounds very very
familiar actually our economy has never
ever been stronger than it is today
cockerel a FERS policies not only
expanded opportunity for our citizens
they spurred economic reforms around the
world and helped lift
untold millions out of poverty art has
advised many world leaders including
former UK Prime Minister Margaret
Thatcher a great one staying true to the
pro-growth vision that doctor laugher
helped develop in 2017 we passed
historic tax cuts and reforms into law
now unemployment has reached its lowest
level in over 51 years with fast-growing
wages low inflation and real GDP and
this is GDP growth that's higher than
anybody ever thought possible first
quarter was 3.2 and everybody said first
quarter is not going to be so good
because first quarter is never very good
for us but it was not only good it was
double and even triple what people
expected and we're gonna see some other
very pleasant surprises especially when
the trade deals are all worked out and
they're coming along very well art as
you know our tax cuts and reforms also
created opportunities owns and distress
communities another idea that dr.
laugher helped develop early in his
career in 1999 Time magazine named dr.
laugher one of the greatest minds of the
20th century former Wall Street Journal
reporter jude wanniski wrote in studying
public finance there is nothing more
important than an appreciation of the
Laffer curve I've heard and studied the
Laffer curve for many years the Wharton
School of Finance it's very important
thing that you've done aren't very
important dr. Lauer helped inspire guide
and implement extraordinary economic
reforms that recognized the power of
human freedom and ingenuity to grow our
economy and lift families out of poverty
and into a really bright future
today our nation is stronger our people
more prosperous and the world a much
better place because of the brilliance
and boldness of doctor author laugher
and it's now my profound honor to ask
the military aide to come forward as I
present dr. laugher with the
Presidential Medal of Freedom it's my
great honor
[Applause]
Arthur B laugher the father of
supply-side economics is one of the most
influential economists in American
history is renowned for his economic
theory the Laffer curve which
establishes the strong incentive effects
of lower tax rates that spur investment
production jobs wages economic growth
and tax compliance among other
accomplishments during his distinguished
career dr. laugher was the first chief
economist of the Office of Management
and Budget and a top economic adviser to
President Ronald Reagan the United
States proudly recognizes Arthur B
laugher for his public service and his
contributions to economic policy which
have helped spur prosperity for our
nation
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
oh my gosh when your staff said keep it
short I didn't know that's what they
meant no I'm just joking thank you very
much
let me play ken sincerity and brevity so
they say go hand in hand and in that
vein mr. president I want to thank you
from the top the middle and the bottom
of my heart thank you good economic
policy is a team effort and goodness
knows my fellow teammates are the best
ever Larry Kudlow my friend forever and
never never Steve Moore where are you
Steve Steve Moore steve forbes steve
forbes cancelled his trip abroad be here
today
does david Malpass here Kevin Hassett
team players
Steven minutia wherever there you are
you're way back there Steve I mean you
don't get a better team than that ever I
mean this is the team of all teams and I
just want to reflect for a second on
some of my past colleagues and working
with other administration's for example
in the past my colleagues included Nobel
laureate and dear friend Bob Mandel the
legendary editorial page editor Bob
Bartley of the Wall Street Journal Jude
Winooski the crazy wild revolutionary
for supply-side economics Milton
Friedman of course my godfather and
dearest supporter Justin dart George
Shultz my mentor who's hired me four
times and not gotten tired of it yet I
guess Jack Kemp who we called the weapon
he's delivered it and my classmate at
Yale my dear friend a guy named Dick
Cheney it's just really wonderful to
have each of whom deserves a lot of
praise by the way just for the record
Bob Bartley Milton Friedman Justin dart
George Shultz Jack Kemp and Dick Cheney
all received the Presidential Medal of
Freedom
isn't that amazing I'm in great great
company let me tell you I'm I'm awed by
that but to get over the to get the ball
over the fun the to get the ball over
the goal line committed leadership is
the scenic waa known for this and we had
President Kennedy President Reagan Prime
Minister Margaret Thatcher and of course
you mr. president Donald Trump to really
make it all happen without the leaders
and all I can say is Wow I mean you know
President Kennedy established the
current Presidential Medal of Freedom
and both President Reagan and Margaret
Thatcher were recipients my business
partners here my business partners
friends and the fellow dreamcatchers a
number of whom are here today by the way
have allowed all of this to happen for
me and I am eternally grateful they are
the salt of the earth and in fact they
actually live the lives that we
economists just talked about they
actually do it and it's for the and it
is for them that we do what we do they
have kept do keep and will keep America
prosperous and my final shout out if I
may is to my family my wonderful family
all six of my children are here today as
well as Mike Madsen and Mike stabile I'm
missing my 13 grandchildren and my four
great-grandchildren for which I'm sure
the White House staff is eternally
grateful my family makes me very very
proud and gives me a reason every
morning to get up and get to work
thank you
this way baby breath Thank You France
right this way thank you
[Music]